for all of the hullabaloo around New
Horizons Pluto flyby it's not like us
earthbound mortals will ever get the
chance to actually fly by we won't get
to experience the glory of drifting over
the dwarf planets icy surface no that
honor belongs to a tiny space probe now
on its way to the outer edges of the
Kuiper belt but this NASA animation gets
you pretty close just take in those
mountain peaks up to 11,000 feet tall
according to scientists and most likely
made out of ice not rock there isn't a
single impact crater in the range which
means they're super young at least in
terms of the solar system's geological
timescale less than 100 million years
old the other amazing part of the
surface is pretty much the exact
opposite
a vast unmarked plane that we know best
as Pluto's heart just north of those icy
crags they sort of look like frozen mud
cracks with each segment spanning about
12 miles across and broken up by
mysterious troughs the astronomers are
still trying to figure out what
geological processes might have formed
these strange features which are coded
by frozen methane and nitrogen humans
may never get to explore Pluto in person
but at least now we know what we'd need
if we did a good pair of crampons and an
ice axe